now that the Screen Actors Guild is
striking alongside the writer's Guild of
America and against the alliance of
motion picture and television producers
Productions are going to start shutting
down in large numbers and that includes
Deadpool 3. that's variety notes this is
the first major Studio production to
shudder due to the strikes this means
that fans are going to have to wait even
longer for Hugh Jackman to return to the
Silver Screen as Wolverine excitement
for the third installment in the
franchise was growing rapidly in recent
days after set photos were released
showing Jackman in a comic accurate
costume alongside Ryan Reynolds Master
vigilante surprisingly Jennifer Garner
is also set to reprise her role as a
lecturer in the R rated 3 core making
Deadpool 3 one of the most anticipated
comic book movies in recent memory now
it looks like the stars will be
picketing until the Guild's demands are
met but here we are overcome our
differences a lot of Productions were
shut down for the duration of the strike
in the coming weeks so why is Deadpool 3
shutting down such big news besides the
fact that the first two Deadpool movies
were universally well received thanks to
Reynolds charming and Central
performance as well as the fact that
they marked as return to superhero
movies after his disastrous turn as a
Green Lantern this movie features two
Marvel characters returning to the fold
in what is sure to be a fourth wall
breaking crowd pleaser Wolverine's
return made enormous waves when news
broke thus it means a long-awaited
return of the X-Men to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is finally underway
after several complicated deals
involving 20th Century Fox and Marvel
the MCU can finally add the X-Men back
into the mix and Wolverine's appearance
is probably one of the most highly
anticipated MCU moments on the horizon
said photos also show Wolverine and
Deadpool battling which is given way to
even more speculation could this
possibly mean that Deadpool and
Wolverine will face off and leave no
survivors giving both Jackman and
Reynolds are send-off worthy of their
Heroes Ghana's Republican was announced
much more recently than Jackman's but
after her appearances and maligned to
movies like 2003's Daredevil and the
2005 solo outing Elektra it'll be nice
to see the actress revive the character
in a more irreverent self-aware
production this is all very exciting but
again fans are gonna have to wait for a
deal to be struck before production can
resume on July 14 2023 at midnight
eastern time the Screen Actors Guild
American Federation of television and
radio artists or sag-aftra officially
joined its brothers and sisters and arms
in the wga on the picket line after
Guild president Fran Drescher delivered
a blunt blistering speech about
corporate greed and the insufficient
deal offered to the guild Drescher said
the eyes of the world and particularly
the eyes of Labor are upon us I can't
believe how far apart we are on so many
things they say they're losing money
left and right while they give hundreds
of millions of dollars to the CEOs at
some point we have to say no we're not
gonna take it anymore if we don't stand
tall right now
we are all going to be in trouble one
major sticking point particularly for
actors is the Advent of artificial
intelligence technology as Chief
negotiator Duncan Crabtree Island said
at the press conference The amptp's
Proposal included a provision that
background actors could be scanned and
their likeness is recorded which could
then be used as extras in future
projects without the person's presence
required to add insult to injury this
would mean the actor would only be paid
for a single day of work we are all
going to be in Jeopardy of being
replaced by machines this is the first
time two girls have been on strike
simultaneously in over 60 years and it
remains to be seen whether or not a
resolution will come anytime soon